[Music]
this is ver money a martial Eagle the
largest African Eagle they have enough
power in one foot to break a human arm
as powerful as they are their strength
in numbers continues to decrease in the
wild martial eagles weigh in at around
14 pounds with a wingspan up to eight
and a half feet bomani is native to
sub-saharan Africa preferring open woods
wooded savanna and thorn bush habitats
he is an apex predator sitting at the
top of the avian food chain
unfortunately they are being persecuted
by humans mistakenly believed to be a
predatory threat to livestock in reality
domestic animals make up a very small
percentage of their diet add to that a
shrinking habitat which reduces prey the
martial eagle population is dwindling
fast this is the martial eagle
[Music]
there are so many Eagles here bald
eagles are our national burden for most
people in the US there are rare and
magnificent sighting but for us it's
just part of our daily lives everybody
in town has an eagle Suri
[Music]
I'm Carlin and Lowe born and raised in
Alaska and I am the Unalaska Visitors
Bureau executive director even though
our island is almost 80 miles long there
are nearly 600 birds in just a few
square miles
which is crazy there's an unnatural
amount of birds here because we
contribute to their food source these
bald eagles are so amazing and we love
seeing them but when they're involved in
your daily life they can make running
errands or your work really difficult
you read something as simple as mailing
a letter can be dangerous I'm officer
would with the an Alaska Department of
Public Safety our department put up
these signs to warn the community about
the dangers of the nesting Eagles which
are right next to the post office Eagles
have been known to swoop down and attack
people they're very territorial and
they're just trying to protect their
nests the eagle's nest is right there
and here is the post office some people
have been hurt during these incidents
but I've also heard some funny stories
I'm Pam Oz and I run bingo here at the
Senior Center every other Sunday I was
carrying this box it had something like
bingo stuff in it all of a sudden a wing
hit my head the talons came down grabbed
the box and flew down the street and I
never saw my bingo box again but if you
want to see a whole lot of eagles you go
to the landfill I'm Steve bastok I work
at the city of Onalaska the landfill
one of my favorite places to be also one
of the Eagles favorite places to be I
know that Eagles are scavengers and
predators so they like trash to they'll
pick up whatever they think might be
food my name is Bob Wilson I've been
fishing out of the Bering Sea and Dutch
Harbor for 40 years Dutch Harbor is one
of the largest fishing ports in the
world every time we pull in we know the
Eagles are waiting for us so they can
steal our fish as we offload it do I
think they're pests oh absolutely but
they're cool pests so that's okay
they make a mess of my boat which is
kind of the bad part but they are
national bird and we love them anyway
how's that
[Music]
[Music]
don't go anywhere being in a bald eagle
nest is surreal this is a wild animal
she's being rowdy
it's very capable of hurting you if
you're not careful so you have to take
your time a little rough huh sorry about
that it's an experience that's hard to
describe my name is Jim Campbell Spitler
I'm a forest canopy ecologist and a
wildlife biologist and I'm pretty sure I
have the best job in the world my job is
to climb into the eagle's nest and
capture and work with chicks
monster and the reason why we're doing
this is we're trying to get blood
samples and we can use those blood
samples to look at environmental
contaminants and how they get into the
bald eagles food source and make me
chase you huh don't you come off there
come down it's a challenging species to
work with it's got a really sharp hooked
beak and its talons are big and powerful
and you don't want to let them grab
ahold of you because they can really do
some damage all right let's go down this
is a wild animal so you never know what
can happen the Channel Islands are an
island chain off the coast of Southern
California these guys know lucky ball
they're a desert island system you get
out there and you can stand on top of
these Bluffs and you can see the Pacific
a whole 360-degree view of just the most
beautiful ocean you can ever imagine
you've got not only bald eagles you have
peregrine falcons that are nesting on
the sea cliffs just tell me if she's
coming in you've got a host of different
seabirds and it's just a magical place a
research it may look invasive but really
one of our primary concerns is the
safety of these young birds that were
handling so we go to great lengths to
ensure that we don't injure them and
that when we put them back in the nest
they're just as well off as when we
first encountered them like you the bald
eagles are national birds so it's quite
an honor for me to get to work with this
species quite often I'll just sit in
that nest for a moment and just take in
the view and just think wow you know
it's just an honor to get up there be
able to share that view and that
experience with them just for that
moment in time
[Music]
this is Jackson a 16 year old golden
eagle we almost lost these beautiful
birds but now they're bouncing back
Golden Eagles are excellent hunters and
extremely fast diving at speeds greater
than a hundred and fifty miles per hour
this makes the Golden Eagle one of the
fastest animals on earth when hunting
they use their sharp talons to grab
their prey Golden Eagles have been known
to hunt animals as large as deer and
gray wolves their feathers are dark
brown with lighter gold around their
head and neck in the 1960s branches
feared that they were eating their
livestock and over 20,000 was shot since
then through education then numbers have
restabilized and their biggest threat
now is habitat loss this is the golden
eagle
[Music]
[Music]
this is the northern bald eagle an
iconic bird that we almost lost for good
only a few decades ago northern Bald
Eagles are the larger of the two
subspecies of the bald eagle their
wingspan can reach over seven feet they
are powerful fliers that soar through
the air reaching over 40 miles per hour
when gliding they're excellent predators
attacking from above with their long and
sharp talons by the 1960s
their population was decimated with less
than 1000 left in the wild chemicals
from pesticides traveled up the food
chain rendering these top predators
sterile or unable to lay healthy eggs
thankfully after massive regulations
were put in place they have made a near
full recovery
today loss of suitable habitat is still
a threat as they are very sensitive to
human activity this is the northern bald
eagle
[Music]
this is the battle or eagle shrinking
habitats and inadvertent poisoning has
caused a major drop in this majestic
birds population
battlers and medium-sized birds but they
have a wingspan of over 6 feet they have
dark black feathers under their white
wings with a red face and legs while
endemic to most parts of Africa they
prefer the urban woodland savannas or
the grasslands the name battle-ax is
French for tightrope walker and
references their distinctive flight
pattern unlike most birds they fly low
to the ground when hunting for prey they
feed on small birds and mammals but are
also carrion eaters
unfortunately farmers will poison dead
carcasses to kill off predators and
batter loose end up ingesting the highly
toxic poisons this is the battle
Louisville
[Music]
you